weapon or no I will defeat you all right
oh just starts off strong
oh so brutal no you won't hit this my
favorite thing is just how simple it is
he just pops you in the head that's so
great
just a little concussion there what is
this I know man this is Rocco Michael
look at this no that's that could be it
for you it's not it's not Oh
DCAM since nobody else is gonna say I
figure I would have been saying I'm sure
though I'm sure the street chance was
blowing up now yeah well they can't make
fun of my hairline today so I'm wearing
a fitted sweatshirt so they so saying
I'm super fat been looking I still AM
door again jump in Oh miss the misty
overhead
here we go here we go you're gonna stand
oh oh under it smart that'll be about
whoa what am i doing hey man it's so
loud over here dear mother duck kicked
about their good pushing shot did you
hear
Lance down oh my god you wonder if he's
actually doing this on purpose or any
magic okay guys
oh you know I'm having a great time I'm
having a great time let's keep talking
about me you know we all have like
things that can get us a limo pretty
badly yeah Derek says if you tell them
to use pushes a lot of buttons
yes hey guys how was everybody's day
okay great the other face day let's talk
about Leatherface yeah like oh no nope
you finished at least it's over he's
done oh oh let him be just let him be
leather face Wow
you